by the way that is not the only area
where democrats are doing exactly the
same thing that they're accusing
republicans of there is a clip that was
just
unearthed from david letterman's old
late show
where joe biden many many years ago when
he could still form a coherent english
sentence went on the show
and and described i kid you not he
described
being arrested for breaking into the
capital
would you call it i don't know an
insurrection i don't know
but but joe biden claims to have been
arrested for the exact same thing
that the crazy guy with the face paint
and the horns was arrested for on
january 6th
what was that like walking into the
great senate chamber
at 29 years old you know i walked in
when i was 21
and i got arrested i was it was a
saturday i was down
visiting some friends at georgetown
university and
i came up on a saturday morning because
i was fascinated with the senate and
then a saturday session i walked up
those days
no guards stopping everywhere and i and
they just got out of session i walked in
the back
all of a sudden i found myself in the
chamber and i was stunned i walked up
sat down the presiding officer's seat
guy grabbed me by the shoulder
said you're under arrest what a classic
joe biden story
did that actually happen probably not
like most joe biden stories he is
probably the most notorious liar in
american politics that's why he had to
drop out of the 1988 presidential
election
but this is an inconvenient probable lie
for joe biden because
he's claiming to do exactly what we are
now told was
the worst insurrection in american
history and the
most calamitous thing that's ever
happened in our country joe biden is
saying yeah i did that when i was 21.
i got arrested for it too but now i'm
old smiling joe now i'm a senator
even you know aoc is not the only member
of her party
who is breaking with rank on this issue
of the migrant children and joe biden
being a total hypocrite
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
michael knowles show to check out the
full episode
hit the link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts
you